(uplifting music)
- I'm astronaut Nicole Mann.
- I am astronaut Frank Rubio.
- I am NASA astronaut Jessica Meir.
- So there's about a million
things going through my mind,
as I think about going to the moon.
- You know that the
little kid inside of me,
just gets super excited.
- For me, that has always
been this dream mission,
this driving exploration and
curiosity of that next step.
- You know, just the excitement,
the amount of effort and the teamwork
that goes into such an amazing expedition
and really what it means to humanity.
So it's very exciting.
- If I can be a part of those
missions in any capacity,
it will truly be a dream come true.
- I think it is important that in 2024,
we're gonna see the first
woman walk on the moon
and the next man.
And it is a huge team effort,
but what it does, it
just shows the diversity
that we have in NASA,
in the United States,
really in the world that the
barriers are broken down.
- I think for all of us that are involved
on this Artemis team,
we would all be absolutely thrilled
to be the first woman on the moon.
And to know that even if it's not me,
that I probably know the first woman
that's going to set foot
on the moon is something
that is so fulfilling.
- So it really wasn't until
a little bit later on in life
that I realized that I
wanted to be an astronaut.
You know, as a young woman,
I was interested in math and science,
but I didn't realize
maybe the possibilities
that were out there.
- My mom says, I first
started saying I wanted
to be an astronaut when
I was five years old.
Everybody associated that with
me all through my childhood.
- My dream was always to be a physician
and to be an army doctor
and then to be a special forces doctor.
And so I was kinda living my dream
and I was in my dream job.
And then a friend recommended
that I try out for the program.
So it was really very late.
- I think for me it was
really a combination of things
of having this fascination
for science and nature
and the world around me.
- The fact that I can continue
to be a part of something
that's bigger than myself.
- So many things out there, you
should never limit yourself.
The possibilities are absolutely endless.
- I think he's pretty excited.
I think, you know,
he's a little worried
about me leaving home
for an extended period of time, I think.
He's only eight,
so I think as any eight
year old kid would be,
but I think he's also very excited
and I tell you it's different now.
Sometimes we always sit outside
and we love to look at the
stars and look at the moon.
But now I think both of us look at it
with a little different light in our eyes
and a little different twinkle,
knowing that, you know,
someday soon we're gonna be,
you know, back there on the moon.
And hopefully someday he'll
be able to watch mom fly by
and walk on the moon.
- When we do hard things
and we challenge ourselves as humanity
to take on big challenges,
it brings us together and it pushes us
to develop new technologies, new ideas.
- I think exploring space is so important,
really for the benefit of all of humanity.
- This is just an innate
characteristic in the human species
to explore.
- Science and technology development,
to exploration of our species as a humans
and where we're going
and where we came from.
- Understanding more
about our solar system,
about our universe, about the formation,
not only of other planetary
objects, like the moon and Mars,
but of our own.
- And you also see the
benefits back on earth
from science development,
and also just inspiring
the next generation.
- We end up changing our lives forever.
And I think for the most part
for the betterment of mankind.
- When you look back at
the planet from above,
you don't see any of those
man-made geopolitical boundaries
that we've imposed upon ourselves.
And it's so easy to realize
how we truly are all in this together.
We are all one.